[Música]
rápidamente yo siempre pensé cuál es la
mejor manera de entregar mi tarjeta de
presentación y yo creo que la manera más
increíble es esta
muy bien pues yo soy diego winder soy
mentalista' ilusionista e hipnotista
ya no habían invitado a una tve antes y
esta es la segunda vez que estoy aquí y
ahora pensé que es lo que yo podría
compartir esta segunda vez y lo único
que tengo como siempre es mi experiencia
ahora le web les voy a convertir una
magia un poco diferente en el 2011 se
murió mi papá
su muerte fue super repentina de repente
un día le dio un infarto y podemos se
murió
durante su vida él me dio muchos regalos
muy increíbles
pero de los más importantes de toda la
vida bueno de los más importantes que me
dio mi papá y que me ha dado la vida en
realidad fue su muerte y les voy a
explicar por qué
cuando me dieron la noticia yo sentí uno
de los dolores más profundos que he
sentido en toda mi vida
pasaban los días y yo lloraba muchísimo
lloraba lloraba y sentía muchísimo dolor
y de repente me empecé a dar cuenta que
empecé a tener una relación nueva con
esta emoción
me hice consciente que yo estaba 100%
siendo este dolor
digo como en un portal para yo poder
estar totalmente en el momento presente
y aquí fue donde yo descubrí la técnica
para dejar de sufrir
y hoy en y hoy se las voy a compartir a
todos
conforme pasaba el tiempo les decía yo
sentía el dolor se hizo este portal y
cuando uno yo me hice consciente cuando
estas cien presente con tus dos uno deja
de sufrir
era tan fuerte lo que yo sentía que no
existía nada más no había más
pensamientos lo único que existía era
este instante este dolor muy cosa estaba
yo 100 por ciento siendo este dolor
y me empecé a dar cuenta cómo se
empezaba a convertir en una paz en una
paz y un sentimiento de seguridad muy
profundo
que yo no entendía bien como estaba
pasando porque esta situación fue algo
inevitable mi papá se murió fue
inevitable y me llevó a darme cuenta que
el sufrimiento realmente es una elección
yo no sabía muy bien cómo estaba pasando
todo esto
pero lo que sí sabía es que cada que yo
sentía este dolor me iba en el momento
presente naturalmente lloraba y lloraba
lloraba pero al final yo sentía una paz
y una seguridad super profunda y yo no
entendía bien por qué
mis papás desde chiquito a mí siempre me
enseñaron que todo el bienestar y la
seguridad y la felicidad está dentro de
nosotros yo había sentido esto en
diferentes ocasiones por ejemplo cuando
te enamoras cuando viajas cuando tienes
un gran logro cuando hago magia pero yo
no lograba sostener está
esta como esta paz interna y también me
di cuenta que yo tenía mi felicidad y
creo que la mayoría de los seres humanos
nuestra felicidad está puesta en algo
externo por ejemplo una relación un
trabajo etcétera y en el momento en el
que algo cambia del afuera toda nuestra
felicidad
se desaparece
y yo ya estaba cansado de este como mal
hábito
y aquí fue cuando decidí dejarlo todo mi
trabajo deje todo y me fui a hacer un
intensivo de meditación de seis meses
donde estábamos todo el tiempo meditando
sin parar todo el tiempo con los ojos
cerrados para lo único que abrimos los
ojos el apoyo al baño para comer para
hacer ejercicio
para expresar lo que estaba pasando
cuando estás meditando por tantas horas
sin parar algo increíble empieza a pasar
todas las emociones que yo tenía como
que estaban
que estaban allí en mi cuerpo guardadas
todas las emociones reprimidas de toda
mi vida que yo no había sabido abrazar
empezaban a salir a la superficie para
que por primera vez yo la supiera
integrar ya que en la vida en realidad
nadie nos enseña cómo lidiar con el
dolor o estas emociones incómodas que
sentimos día con día
entonces me fui a hacer este intensivo
de meditación ahí estaba yo meditando
miles de horas
y de las primeras cosas que yo me di
cuenta que no importa qué es lo que esté
sintiendo
si tú cierras los ojos te conectas
contigo mismo sientes de emoción
simplemente las sientes poco a poco esto
se empieza a convertir en una paz como
en una presencia muy simple y empieza a
transformarse ya liberarse las emociones
por ejemplo yo empezaba a sentir
muchísima ansiedad
pero por primera vez yo no me podía
distraer de esto porque normalmente
empezamos a sentir tristeza miedo lo que
sea y nos distraemos instantáneamente
con las redes sociales con la fiesta con
lo que sea y yo por primera vez no me
podía distraer solo me tenía que quedar
ahí sentado con los ojos cerrados
sintiendo mi ansiedad
empezó ahí me empecé a dar cuenta esto
es lo que me pasó cuando se murió mi
papá
yo a través de la ansiedad me conectaba
conmigo dije y me iba 100% al momento
presente lo que había pasado de una
manera inevitable con los sentimientos y
el dolor de mi papá
me conectaba con esta ansiedad y de
repente algunas veces se disolvía
instantáneamente
y otras veces no y me daba cuenta que
detrás de la ansiedad había un mar de
emociones que yo había reprimido durante
toda la vida y que estaban guardadas en
mi sistema nervioso
y por primera vez tenía oportunidad de
integrarlas
y aquí fue donde entre más yo hacía esto
en cuenta de esta habilidad increíble
que tenemos y mientras meditaba también
de repente cuando empezaba a conectarme
con las emociones incómodas mi cabeza
instantáneamente se disparaba pum y
empezaba a pensar millones y millones de
pensamientos algunos relacionados con me
emocionan tal es una historia otros nada
que ver nada más mi mente se iba un
drama que me hacía sentirme aún peor
entonces aquí fue cuando me empecé a dar
cuenta de esto pasaban miles y miles de
horas sentí que me volví no loco hasta
que me canse
porque en seis meses de esto no y yo no
llegué a un punto de cero pensamiento
pero lo que sí me di cuenta es que yo
podía dejar de escuchar a mi cabeza
por ejemplo ustedes todo el día tienen
un tenedor en la mano
yo no soy un tenedor no cuando tenemos
un tenedor
solamente cuando vamos a comer
exactamente
si yo tuviera un tenedor en mi mano todo
el día mi día sería extremadamente
disfuncional
de igual forma yo me di cuenta con mis
pensamientos obviamente hay que utilizar
el pensamiento para las cosas prácticas
para planear mi día
pero en el momento en el que nos damos
cuenta que ya mi pensamiento me está
llevando a lugares de sufrimiento ahí
tenemos que parar y soltar y dejarlo de
escuchar y este es el momento donde para
mí me di cuenta de que uno puede ser el
maestro de nuestros pensamientos y no
una víctima de nuestros pensamientos
esta es la gran diferencia entre ser un
creador o una víctima en mi experiencia
cuando tú eres capaz ahora de elegir lo
que tú quieres pensar porque en lo que
nos estamos enfocando esto es lo que
vamos a crear en la vida el enfoque es
el arquitecto de nuestra realidad
entonces práctica esto lo hice muchas
veces salí de esta experiencia me di
cuenta de algo increíble dije guau acabo
de describir para mí la mejor magia del
mundo
esta capacidad de ser un creador elegir
mis pensamientos conectarme con mis
emociones irme 100% del momento presente
y transformar mis emociones en paz en
seguridad y en esta presencia que yo me
sentía
totalmente en paz que es exactamente lo
que había pasado naturalmente cuando se
murió mi papá y esto es a lo que yo
llamo la alquimia de las emociones
la capacidad de elegir mi pensamiento
conectarme con mis emociones
simplemente sentirlas decirles 100% que
sí
y ser un testigo de cómo estas emociones
se transforman y se convierten en paz en
seguridad en amor
y en un piso como super sólido adentro
de mí esta es 100% mi experiencia y hoy
en día se las quiero compartir ahora
para mí lo más importante de esto es que
ustedes tengan una experiencia directa
de lo que estoy diciendo porque si no
siento que yo digo esta es mi
experiencia que padre pero pues si a
ustedes que no
entonces
quisiera lo más importante también para
mí es lograr sostener cuando uno se
siente muy bien cuando estás enamorado
cuando te sientes bien en la vida o
puede que iguale alguien estás meditando
y te sientes muy bien con los ojos
cerrados pero qué pasa en ese instante
cuando ya estás ahí en el momento con tu
mamá con tu esposo con tu esposa con tu
novio te sientes celos o con miedo lo
que sea que está sintiendo podemos hacer
lo importante para mí es lograr sostener
esta plenitud y hacer la alquimia de las
emociones
y ser los maestros de nuestro
pensamiento entonces voy a les voy a
compartir una técnica que yo aprendí
así que quieren todos practicar esto un
minuto
muy bien
para lograr sostenerte con los ojos
cerrados pero también con los ojos
abiertos entonces voy a compartir desde
mi experiencia de esta técnica vamos a
practicarla puede ser que un minuto
entonces vamos a pensar una cosa yo
siempre me enfoco en algo de amor de
gratitud
entonces les voy a dar un pensamiento
super poderoso para en lugar de que tu
cabeza cuando tu cabeza punto uno está
como loca tú eliges tu pensamiento y te
conviertes en el creador de tu
existencia y el pensamiento es éste
amor me crea en mi perfección entonces
pueden repetir todos amor
me crea en mi perfección amor de crear y
perfección y esto es simplemente para
que tu mente se enfoque en algo de
gratitud de una buena un buen
sentimiento entonces ahorita los voy a
dirigir yo van a ser los ojos van a
pensar amor me creo y perfección y se
van a enfocar adentro de ustedes mismos
y sólo van a escanear su cuerpo los voy
a ir guiando es que ni en su cuerpo a
ver si existe cualquier sentimiento
emoción lo que sea y volvemos a pensar
si tu mente va a decir a que se estudie
govern water ex no sé y otra vez amor me
creo y perfección o haya mi querido amor
me cree mi perfecto no regresas te
conectas contigo y tan sólo quiero que
estén ahí sentados y que sean
incondicionales un minuto con ustedes
mismos los voy a ir guiando
y en el momento en el que sienten una
paz muy profunda
lentamente lentamente vamos a ir
abriendo los ojos están listos
sí o no ok entonces una dos tres en los
ojos
despiden profundo
y vamos a pensar amor me crea en mi
perfección
una vez más amor me crea en mi
perfección y vamos a sentir nuestro
cuerpo desde los pies
sentimos la ropa como toca nuestra piel
los calcetines los dedos de los pies
cualquier energía que esté ahí
vamos pasando desde los pies por las
piernas
igual y se siente como un cosquilleo ahí
adentro la energía que está dentro de
nuestro cuerpo vamos al estómago y nos
vamos a relajar cada vez más y más
profundo más y más profundo más y más
profundo
nos conectamos con cualquier cosa vamos
al estómago somos conscientes de lo que
está pasando
llevamos nuestra atención al pecho y
profundo no quiero que había un profundo
profundo y puede que existe alguna
emoción algún sentimiento en el estómago
o puede que exista algún tipo de
sensación en el pecho sentimiento y nada
más quiero que lo observen y lo sientan
que sean incondicionales y que se
permitan que le permitan que este
sentimiento sea
simplemente lo vamos a observar
cualquier pensamiento que llegue en
lugar de ser víctimas vamos a hacer
creadores amor me crea en mi perfección
pasamos por el pecho el cuello y la
cabeza
y vamos super profundo profundo profundo
llevamos toda nuestra acción a nosotros
toda nuestra atención al pecho y vamos
muy profundo muy profundo amor me cree
en mi perfección y si existe una emoción
vamos a ver que hay alrededor de esta
emoción o hacer que las sentimos y poco
a poco vamos a ver cómo se empieza a
disolver y empieza a cambiar algo nuevo
empieza a suceder adentro de nosotros
cuando somos incontables incondicionales
y nos permitimos sentir
y una vez que ustedes se encuentra en
una paz profunda que sientas que te
sientes en paz que encuentras este lugar
de paz muy lentamente muy lentamente
vamos a ir abriendo los ojos
lentamente abren los ojos y encuentras
está este sentimiento de paz de
tranquilidad
lentamente abre los ojos y en el momento
en el que lo pierdas vuelves a cerrar
los ojos
y esto es como un ejercicio como un
músculo que podemos ir trabajando en la
vida con los ojos abiertos con los ojos
cerrados cuando sientas esta paz te
conectas
a ver los ojos intenta sostener esto y
si lo pierdes vuelves a cerrar los ojos
y así esta técnica en realidad a mí me
ha cambiado la vida porque yo puedo
sostener esta experiencia con los ojos
cerrados pero también con los ojos
abiertos y ya sé cuál es el camino que
me lleva a esta paz que tengo adentro de
mí
así que bueno espero
un momento de paz yo soy de govern
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]